hey another new movie i'm liking this oh
i forgot this was coming out
[Music]
capone so capone's directed by josh
trank he directed chronicle and
totally giving him a pass on fan
fourstick i will say he came up with
what could have been an interesting idea
for a fantastic four movie so now we
have a story of al capone kind of
like not a story you would expect when
you hear that there's a story about al
capone because al capone had syphilis
and his mental state just started
declining and
now we're here this is that movie it's
the movie of someone's mental state
deteriorating and we see them going mad
in that it's gonna require a lot from a
couple people in this movie first and
foremost tom hardy funny enough
the dude's always great and i can think
of a few movies where i'm like you
mumbled and grown a lot
but is he great in those movies yes he
absolutely is and he's great in this
movie i mean at a point in this movie he
couldn't physically do much but don't
ever make the mistake of thinking okay
sweet the actor
he just doesn't have to worry about the
physicality anymore oh no
that's still important tom hardy makes
it work anytime you can walk away from a
movie like this
and you're like i really felt like that
person was mentally
declining yeah also linda cardellini
plays al capone's wife a lot rests on
her shoulders in this one although
i was actually really interested in his
mental decline a lot rests on her
shoulders because she's the heart and
soul of the movie i know nothing about
the real person when it comes to her
heck i'm not even an al capone
aficionado but really this whole
situation and how it impacts her and how
it rests on her shoulders that's the
heart and soul of the movie that's
really the reason you care you give a
[ __ ] because
it's just a horrible situation for her
to be in so tom hardy had to sell the
mental decline of al capone she had to
sell
us in caring because we care about her
and i weirdly dug this movie i mean it's
not a perfect movie it definitely has
issues
pacing and otherwise but i was really
digging this different
look into al capone's life usually al
capone and tommy guns and murder and
mayhem and there are
bloody segments in this movie usually
dealing with hallucinations he's having
or memories
i was enjoying the fact that we got this
other kind of look into his life that
not many movies really give us
in that yeah it feels like it should be
more of a companion piece to your
general
knowledge of al capone it assumes you
know who this guy is and
that's a pretty fair assessment a fair
assumption if ever there was one most
people know that al capone was a
murderous mobster but if by chance you
don't
know who he is and you don't really know
what al capone did
then you're just gonna watch this movie
like why do i care which
it helps to have her involved but still
it doesn't give you everything it
doesn't give the ground work it doesn't
give you the setup
just go into this movie knowing who al
capone is watch one of the movies
or wikipedia search and that's what
you're gonna have to know going into
this movie you don't get all the tommy
gun action and the mayhem it's not the
untouchables so we're still being
watched by the fbi
which is a small part of it i feel like
there's a little bit of false
advertising going on imdb has a proper
description for those movies the 47-year
al capone after 10 years in prison
starts suffering from dementia and comes
to be haunted by his violent past an apt
description if ever there was one that
is what the movie is about now let's
look at amazon which is how i saw this
movie alfonso capone tom hardy is a
ruthless businessman and bootlegger who
once ruled chicago with an iron fist
in an effort to retain his fortune he
hides away millions of dollars in a
place that only he knows and everyone
else is dying to uncover in this
harrowing and true untold story of his
life capone will stop at nothing to
protect himself
his family and his money what the [ __ ]
that is not
at all what the movie's about i mean
it's in here
sure yeah but that's like the
description of empire strikes back being
like
after accidentally stumbling across
stormtroopers in the cloud city c3po's
now broken body hides an important
message for his friends
i mean it's in there but that's not what
the movie's about do not go into capone
expecting some big grand chase for his
money and he's gonna protect it if
you're gonna watch capone you gotta
watch capone with the mindset of i wanna
see this
decline of this person's mental state
this former mobster's mental state i
want to see the things that haunt him
now i actually really like that the fact
that this person
as they've aged you can blame it on the
dementia sure well that's probably the
reason but i like the fact that it
showed that you do monstrous things
early on in your life and when you get
older do those things haunt you i don't
know if that's how it was
but it made for some interesting cinema
for me and it did a good job at blurring
the lines for the viewer of
where the sanity is ending and where the
insanity's beginning most movies would
make
that confusing sometimes it was
confusing but i never got the feeling
that that's not how i was supposed to
feel i felt like i was
experiencing the dementia as the movie
was trying to make me experience it in
the end i'll say capone was a solid time
no alcohol required ursula capone have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite tom hardy
performance
everything from shinzon of remus to
peltz you comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you